دله الحكومه الافغانيه اغلاق الجامعات
امام الفتيات في عموم البلاد من جهته وصف
الزعيم الحزب الاسلامي قلب الدين حكم تيار
هذا القرار بغير المنطقي وقال ان
المسؤولين الحاليين غير قادرين على تدريب
من جانبه اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيوغوترش عن قلقه العميق لهذا القرار
وكانت نحو 40% من الجامعات الخاصه قد
اغلقت بسبب الاوضاع الماديه السيئه كما
غادر اكثر من 100 استاذ جامعي البلاد وده
وصول طالبان الى السلطه يذكر ان قرار
اغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات ياتي بعد
قرار اخر لطالبا منعت فيه فتح المدارس
المتوسطه والثانويه للبنات
وقد وصف المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ستيفاندوجاليك قرر الحكومه
الافغانيه بحظر التعليم الجامعي على
الفتيات بالخطوه المقلقه للغايه
اخر لقد عينه منذ سيلائهم على السلطه
وكذلك في الاشهر الماضيه تقليل مساحه
النساء ليس فقط في التعليم ولكن في الوصول
الى الاماكن العامه وعدم مشاركتهم في
النقاش العامه انها خطوط اخرى مقلقه
وان يتعامل مع كل التحديات التي يواجهها
دون المشاركه الفعاله للمراه وتعليمها
بدانا نائبه المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي روبرتوود قرار منع النساء من
التعليم الجامعي في افغانستان واضاف اود
انه لا يمكن لحركه طالبان ان تتوقع ان
تكون عضوا شرعيا في المجتمع الدولي حتى
تحترم حقوق جميع الافغان وخاصه النساء
والفتيات
التعليم العالي
الخاصه ان الولايات المتحده تدين باشد
العبارات هذا الموقف الذي لا يمكن الدفاع
عنه اطلاقا لا يمكن الايطالي
شرعيا في المجتمع الدولي حتى تحترم حقوق
جميع الافغان وخاصه حقوق الانسان والحريات
الاساسيه للنساء والفتيات
اعربت الخارجيه القطريه في تغريده عن
قلقها البالغ وعن خيبه املها من قرار
تعليق الدراسه للفتيات والنساء في جامعه
افغانستان وقالت ان الممارسات السلبيه
سيكون لها بالغ الاثر على حقوق الانسان
والتنميه اضافت وزاره الخارجيه الى دوله
قطر تدعو حكومه تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه
الى مراجعه قرارها بما يتسق مع تعليم
الدين الاسلامي فيما يتعلق بحقوق المراه
وجدت التزامها بالعمل مع الشركاء لضمان
التمتعه كل فئات الشعب الافغاني بحقهم في
التعليم